the Tesla family just got bigger so do
you want to see the car the model three
is fine be here it's sleek quick as hell
and meant for the masses well the
middle-class masses and it is the most
important car Tesla will ever build CEO
Elon Musk is convinced the model 3 will
push electric vehicles into the
mainstream starting price is $35,000 but
musk promises you'll pay twenty seven
thousand five hundred dollars after you
get those federal tax credits while the
new model three costs around half of
what the Model S does Tesla isn't
skimping on features the four-door sedan
seats five adults in all the comfort and
practicality you'd expect of an upscale
sedan Tesla's autopilot feature comes
standard it has enough power to reach
zero to 60 miles per hour in under six
seconds and it feels much faster than
that the battery you will have a range
of 215 miles between charges it's
already a hot commodity before mask even
pulled the sheet off the model three
115,000 customers had put $1,000 down to
reserve a car for purchase and the order
numbers continued to rise they'll have
to wait patiently though the model 3
will be delivered to customers in 2017
it will be
hmm hopefully 2017